I love the besties showing up with the tips
yes I would get cash out at the grocery store
however sometimes that shit does show up on your bank statement
like I don't know if you girls have access to the bank statements
but sometimes if you look at the bank statement
it'll say like the grocery store and it'll say the amount like 95 86
and then it'll say $20 cash back
so be careful with that one
it does work is a good way to get money instantly
but if he's checking the bank statement
double check that on the bank statement
it doesn't give away that you got cash back
but yes read the comments
for all the tips on how to fucking get
out of that shit ass relationship you're in
cause you don't need to stay miserable
you don't need to be
no you don't need to be giving up your life for nobody
buy you some fucking TV dinners and take a fucking night off
you don't need to be nobody's personal slave